life changes I'll say just final
thoughts and I'll just kind of turn it
over to you guys marriage is risky
staying single is riskier
having kids is risky
being childless is riskier okay
believing in God is risky not believing
in God is riskier
being part of a startup is risky taking
the safe route is riskier making
investment is risky not making any
Investments is riskier this whole notion
of what's risky and what's even marriage
you're like well in America it's the
worst place to get married
you're right
I agree I don't disagree you know we're
talking to uh a person who lives in uh
Chile
and this person's going through a
divorce
that's a girl going through a divorce
and I said so how are things with the
divorces as well in our country
everything's about the man
this is what do you mean he says it's
not like America
ear if I want to take my kids to the
states he has to give me permission to
take my kids to the states
so guess what in Chile if you get
married men are more protected than who
women in America who's protected it
doesn't matter what you say she's
protected right okay but guess what can
we be a little bit more wiser in the way
we get married can we have better
lawyers to write up a better prenuptial
instead of being cheap and spending
fifteen hundred dollars on a prenuptial
can we spend eight thousand dollars or
five thousand dollars yes can we
structure especially if you don't if you
have money if you don't have money
getting married you can't [__] about it
because you were broke before you got
married but if you are if you are a guy
that has money and then you get married
and you then have to get 50 you were
lazy you didn't want to go go out there
and get the right prenuptial in place we
can make the better choice as a man to
lead the family all of those things are
in US sometimes I also believe this this
messaging of you know what we're doing
and you know women are this and women
are dead and men are this and men are
dead
totally fine hey you know all men are
dogs okay you can say that all you want
you know all men are dogs all they're
going to do is they're going to do this
this is that to you good luck thinking
that way for the rest of your life go
ahead believe your mom well you know
your father cheated on me so many times
Mary let me tell you all men are dogs
Mary go ahead and believe that see how
that pans up for your life let me tell
you all women they're all better this
right there no problem go think that and
then
you're on a day with the scroll it's
getting seriously like this could be my
wife
and then at some point in the
relationship after like six 12 months or
maybe let's just I'm gonna marry this
girl you know when you're looking at it
what you're telling yourself here's what
you're thinking you're saying
okay I'm probably gonna marry you
I think there's a 60 chance this thing's
gonna work out
I think it's a 70 chance this is going
to work out
I think 50 we're going to make it work
you'll never tell her this but you're
gonna have that moment where you think
about it okay if you're not thinking
about it you're drunk but let's just say
you're you're not drunk and you're
thinking about it you're going to say
that if you say a hundred percent this
is going to work out you're a fool
and you're naive
no one's going to get married to zero
percent chance working out why would you
get married but you have a number that
you think about and then your job is for
the remaining 30 or 40 percent
is to lead better
is to put better systems in place to put
better structure in place
to make sure if you know you can't do it
by yourself hey maybe we need a little
bit of God maybe we need to go out with
more people that are married happily
married and Surround ourselves around
them maybe we've got to drop some of the
single guys in our lives single friends
in our lives maybe we need to
re-prioritize what then you increase
your chances but you know we need more
men I went through the evolution myself
as a 90 tenor trust me when when my
sergeant came out of the army he was at
our house and everybody wanted to hear
stories I said Felix tell whatever story
you want to tell he says you sure I said
whatever story you want to tell tell
them
some of the stories you told you
wouldn't believe it you're like Pat did
that Pat did that that's pretty shitty
wow I was very selfish
why hey almost every man that goes
through the selfish phase you know what
the pre-record you know what the
requirement the prerequisite is a format
to become a 90-10 when they just run
through 50 100 girls you know what the
prerequisite is one girl cheats on you
some of the some of the best men most
powerful men in the world one girl one
girl screws them over and then they're
like you know what done here's what I'm
gonna get even with you by going through
this totally get it we've all been
through it
and then after you've done what you've
done eventually you're still going to be
like
you know what ah there's still a risk
I'm willing to take that risk but here's
I'm going to take the risk let's go play
ball
and then if you think
you think you're gonna find a better man
out there go ahead
good luck to you
I'm gonna give the argument there's no
way in the world you're going to find
somebody like that and guess what your
job is to me wife what's that
your job is to also tell me good luck
finding somebody that's going to have
your back better than me good luck good
luck finding somebody that's going to
support you as much as I'm going to
support you that that level of
accountability from both sides makes
both people improve okay and then you
know I'm watching this one recording
between four couples
one is a newly they're about to get
married one is a newly married one
they're in their 30s 40s they've been
married for like 15 20 years and one
they've been married for 40 years so
everybody's given the problems that
they're going through okay then ones
that have been married for four years
they're in their 60s they say yeah it's
great well let me tell you let me tell
you what happened with us my wife she
had to get a surgery done for nine
months we couldn't have sex
for nine months we can have sex at all
says we were in our late 50s I was upset
I was calling out my wife I was fighting
my wife I was blaming her I was saying I
should go get a girl on the side all
this other stuff and they know what God
did two years later what I couldn't have
sex for two years
what my thing wouldn't come up he's
architect Cialis I could take to get
nothing would happen to me I really had
a condition that I was going through
he says now explain life to you
your wife can't leave you now you could
have left her she could leave you now
the the point with life he's trying to
say is trust me you're going to go
through a lot of [__] and you're just
going to hope that someone's gonna be
there during a good time like that when
you're going through it again this is
some of this fluffy stuff people don't
want to hear about this kind of fluffy
stuff they want to hear about calling
out chicks and all this that's more
entertaining though when I'm this is
boring [__] trust me I know it is I'm
telling you it's boring stuff but I'm
telling you
later on in life when you're investing
into things that outlive you the high is
a higher hot bigger high when I was
younger life was hard and annoying the
way I was able to go through shitty
times I had some people in my life that
were very negative and bitter the only
way I was able to get through it is to
have something to look forward to and it
was Sunday NBA games
that was it yeah so it was Wednesday I'm
going through some crying in my house
non-stop all I'm looking forward is
something on Sunday if you have more
things to look forward to in life
you come from a different place you
perform better you handle problems in a
different way you're a little bit more
patient because you have so many more
things to look forward to
and it's very hard to position yourself
to be there because that also comes with
a lot of pain heartache risk because the
same we have a lot of things to look
forward to is also means a lot of [__]
can break yeah a lot of things can go
against you but the alternative is just
not a life worth living for I can't tell
you you got Chef pbd in the kitchen
cooking right now okay I agree with what
you said 110 folds but could we just
adjust the marriage thing I I think
marriage is great but in a certain
context so for example where you do it
and how you do it so let's say we can
get married but not by the state or if
you get married outside the U.S what do
you think
to get married in the states or outside
the U.S so for example basically without
the government being yeah
which I agree with yeah that's not I
don't care about that to me listen
you're talking about the actual I'm
talking about the marriage in itself you
don't care about this now okay
so listen baby by the way you can put a
structure and say babe I'm gonna get
married I'm not going to get married by
the government but I'm going to get
married based on our religion our church
you're good with that of course I'm not
getting married that's no problem
perfect there you go Chad yeah you can
do it smart yeah yeah I think as long as
you don't have to stay involved where
she could take you to the cleaners and
destroy you uh and you mitigate for risk
I think that's that's something that's a
little bit more acceptable uh or you
just have four wives so they behave
anyway
where are you planning on getting these
four wives I have to ask you uh uh well
just in his defense no he's doing it
right now
okay you know
allegedly you know concubines just for
context man yes we went on a double date
well
just submit on a double date Hold on Me
Myron well to make it more realistic
that's how you guys met no no recently
right
um imagine if that's how the Friendship
podcast started yeah
you guys are the gentlemen
yeah he goes with three girls so I think
he's doing it very well right now he's
he's mastering the skills of like by the
way do you know Ronald Reagan there was
a book called Kill Em Reagan okay
and when Reagan went through the first
divorce with Jane weinman what Jane
what's your last name yeah why did I say
correct yes when they went through a
divorce
this was the first time he was single
and he was at he was a b Hollywood actor
extremely handsome in his late 30s or
mid 30s something like that you know
what advice he got because at that time
he hadn't been with too many girls
the number was like he had been with 10
girls Ronald Reagan one of the advice he
got from a lot of people says listen
you're not going to be single for too
long go have as much fun right now as
possible and the story of that in the
book kill on Reagan is Reagan went on a
two-year run where he was just playing
and having a blast
and then he gets that out of his system
because the problem is if you don't get
that out of your system later on what
about this and what about that and what
about this do what you got to do right
now but I'm telling you eventually it's
going to be you can be bored out of your
mind well this is the exact conversation
we had when you were on salescast and
and what Ben Shapiro reacted to oh yeah
when I was like listen when should a guy
consider getting married you said 35
years old should have 6 to 12 saved up
yeah you should be making 100K a year
should we have his Fitness on point and
he should be with 50 50 women and I
jokingly I was like all right time for
me to get married how about that phase
in a season of my life yeah and Ben
Shapiro had a meltdown yeah yeah he went
crazy he did not understand that concept
yeah yeah yeah but if you can do that I
certainly need to think you should uh
explore those options yeah I mean you
know I think that's kind of Ben Shapiro
you know just yeah you know he he went
he got not exactly the ladies man yeah
he got lucky and he basically lost The
Virginian married the woman that he's
currently with and it worked out which
is fantastic that's great but to go
ahead and try to attribute that to the
rest of the male population in 2023 when
we know women are more promiscuous than
ever before we don't have religion as a
buffer anymore social media a father
figure a lot of the times in these
households like all the buffers and the
training wheels that kept women in line
and kept them like you know honest and
good nurturing women they're kind of
gone from society and if anything
societies incentivize women to this guy
if anything society's kind of
incentivized women to behave in a way
that isn't to being a good girl and a
loyal girl for you as a man so I just
say to combat that you got to have these
things in place for you but you know Ben
Shapiro doesn't understand that the
dating game has changed significantly
from when he got married I mean when did
he get married like maybe five years ago
something like that yeah like even even
in the past five years has changed
significantly
also I I would say this I was on the
Andrew Schultz podcast three days ago in
New York what's today today's Monday
Thursday
I was on Schultz's podcast and I'm a big
short Sky I think the guys but to me is
the modern day Johnny Carson anyways I'm
a big fan of the guy I think he's a pure
talent
um but I'm sitting there with them and
he's got his four other guys on the set
with me okay his crew your boy Akash
yeah okay Akash being one of them by the
way you know Akash has only had sex with
one girl in his life
named Mark same as well Mark Akash I
think he's a very good looking guy and
Mark I also think's a very good looking
guy
what is the point late shows date shows
they chose this ride to me what I think
to me is
the the problem is just as much of where
you're looking for to grow as it is the
girl so if I'm going to the club to find
a wife you're you're gambling yeah but
if I go to a church or Community I'm a
part of I'm like I keep telling this guy
go to the temple keep going to the
temple this guy's Temple is the
nightclub
the Jewish girls and he says he wants to
get married you don't want to get
married he's like battling I'll be
player be this be that be this and and
FYI the longer this goes and the more
options you have the harder it is to get
let me say this here we go for most men
out there there we go if you can pick
the size path of being 40 having
you know money muscles game frame that
whole thing playing your field having a
great having options yeah or going the
Ben Shapiro Akash route yeah gentlemen
yeah test drive as many [__] cars as
you possibly can before you buy a
vehicle for the rest of your life I I
would I would debate that
and I'm telling you I'm not a caution
I'm not Ben Shapiro I'm not no I'm
telling you I'm not either one you're
not advocating marrying one woman the
first girl you slept with but I'm I'm
not advocating that that either but I am
Telling You for somebody that is in the
faith-based community yeah Ben Shapiro
is Jewish Akash is not Jews I think
Akash is is an Indian guy is Akash
Indian I don't know what nationality is
yeah so is Hindu yeah if it is within
that Community
um go at it and by the way you're
thinking you know you've been smooth let
me tell you guys a crazy story this this
is the problem with this guy okay I'm in
uh uh where am I was that in Montana or
was I in uh uh
I'm an aspen check this out I go to the
Four Seasons to get a massage okay
this girl comes out to give me the
massage so I'm sparking in a
conversation so where are you from I
live here where are you originally from
Miami oh really yeah well what part of
Miami such and such what college you go
to Florida State how old are you uh 40.
okay do you know a guy named Adam
sosnick she stops how do you know Adam I
said how do you know Adam he says well
no I'm trust me I know what you're
asking I'm not the one it wasn't really
me it was really my girlfriend and you
know I'm like say it what is he doing
nowadays what's he up to this can happen
once a month with this guy okay with
what this guy's been around not with
women just people you know you're saying
I mean it can happen with guys as well
apparently that one we have to pause
she's gonna cut that last part no but
the point you're working the point is
access and networking FYI FYI yeah there
are a lot of people that would love to
be Ben Shapiro right now you can say
what you want to say about Ben I know
for sure there's a lot of people that
will love to and I I've now taken Ben
Shapiro route I I was not ready I was
not a guy that believed in marriage I
was anti the institutional marriage I
did not believe in it I was an atheist
for 25 years of my life I was super
paranoid super skeptical and then one
day I'm like yeah I'm changing my
strategy I think I was 28 when I did
that so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign